[Music]
hello and welcome back to trevor
phillips on sunday
thank you for joining us in the good old
days we could always describe what would
happen in politics during the summer
break with just three words
absolutely naf all
not only longer you turn your back for a
day out on canvas sand or blackpool and
all hell breaks loose the american-led
forces scuttle out of afghanistan and
the taliban march in
tens of thousands are still desperate to
get out of kabul
and covet never takes a holiday schools
are back and winter is coming and with
it maybe new variants along with serious
concerns about flu
uh this autumn nobody in politics can
credibly continue to hide behind the
urgency of tackling covid
globally if the americans won't lead the
west who will and here at home can the
conservatives continue to shake that
magic money tree and still call
themselves tories
as for labor we know they don't like
boris johnson but what exactly are they
for
well we're joined by a top team of
guests who we hope have some answers
joining us today from the government
vaccines minister nadim zahawi
discussing vaccines public spending and
more former prime minister gordon brown
the shadow foreign secretary lisa nandy
will be speaking to me about labour's
take on the taliban and taxation
matthew taylor from the nhs
confederation will be here with us to
talk about the problems facing patients
this winter
and foreign affairs committee chair tom
tuggenheart will be making his own
governments marking his own government
performance over the disaster in
afghanistan
but first we're joined by the minister
for vaccine deployment nadim zahawi good
morning minister
good morning
um
before we turn to covet can i
just ask you about the aftermath of the
pull-out from afghanistan um do you or
anyone else in government actually know
how many british citizens
are left in kabul or in afghanistan and
who want to get out
good morning
philip so trevor forgive me um
of course the foreign secretary who is
traveling in the region and is making
sure that anyone who is looking to get
up who is either a uk citizen or
qualified uh to
have that uh ability uh for safe haven
in the united kingdom
can do so uh and as the foreign
secretary said to the
foreign affairs select committee and i
know you've got tom toughenhart later on
on your program
that the numbers are in the low hundreds
uh the important thing to remember is
the
evacuation um
of 15 000
of people in a very short space of time
um
is a real tribute both to our armed
forces and of course to our foreign
office and ambassador uh specifically in
afghanistan who and his team did a
tremendous job
but we continue to make sure that
we hold the taliban to account in terms
of providing safe
routes out of the country for those who
are looking to leave the country and as
the foreign secretary has said it is in
the low hundreds
that we are still looking to
deliver safe haven for
all returnees who are uk citizens
those those
those few hundred of course are
if you like the most difficult cases we
know that many of them are actually
in hiding can you say anything obviously
without endangering their security about
what we're doing to ensure the the
evacuation
of those
frankly terrified people
well and you're quite right and i think
it's very important that when we deal
with such sensitive cases
um that some of the detail is clearly
kept
confidential and i can assure you
that the foreign office
or the agencies uh the ministry of
defense are all engaged to make sure
that
those uh people are able to get out as
well as of course uh the foreign
secretary dominic rabb holding the
taliban to account in terms of
delivering that safe route out of the
country
for those who are looking to leave and
to return to the united kingdom
are you genuinely depending on the
taliban's goodwill
well i think holding the taliban to
account if
that is what you mean then we have to
hold them to account
on this and i think the foreign
secretary is doing the right thing by
corralling um the both the the sort of
the neighboring countries uh and those
countries that have the greatest
influence over the taliban
to make sure that we
um
make sure that they deliver on their
promise that anyone who wants to leave
the country and has um a
country of safe haven to welcome them
like the united kingdom
is able to do so
all right let's let's turn to kobed now
which is your own territory we
understand that the joint committee
vaccines and immunization
has decided that
it can't recommend
that
children between 12 and 15 should be
vaccinated yet
you and other ministers have decided to
ask the chief
medical officers of the four nations to
examine
whether you should ignore that advice so
so when did we all stop being guided by
the science
well actually that that is not factually
correct the joint committee on
vaccination and immunization has done a
brilliant job uh for us for me
throughout the pandemic
whether it be the prioritization if you
remember
they prioritized the most vulnerable to
serious infection and to hospitalization
and death and that turned out to be a
very good piece of advice so we listened
very carefully to jcbi
their latest deliberation on healthy
children and it's worth just reminding
your viewers that we have already been
taking the advice of the jcbi and
vaccinating young
people 12 to 15 year olds who are more
vulnerable to serious infection from
covert so those who are at a higher risk
are already being
inoculated vaccinated as as per the
advice
the jcvi
if you read their advice
on balance it is marginally more
beneficial to
vaccinate 12 to 15 year olds healthy 12
15 year olds is what they said but not
enough for them to recommend a
national vaccination program for healthy
12 to 15 year olds and they are the ones
who said that the chief medical officers
should look beyond what they are
qualified to look at so they looked at
things that they are qualified to look
at but they also recognize that there
are areas
that the chief medical officers chris
whittie and his fellow chief medical
officers in the devolve administration
should look at in terms of uh the
vaccination of healthy 12 year olds
and that is exactly what they'll do now
we have not made any decisions so we
haven't uh to your question
decided not to listen to the experts on
the contrary
all four ministers
so the secretary of state decided javid
and his fellow ministers
in the devolved administration have
agreed to ask the chief medical officers
to convene expert groups including the
jcbi being in that
to be able to recommend which way we
should go on healthy 12 to 15 year olds
but we are vaccinating those at highest
risk the 12 15 year olds at highest risk
we already are vaccinated thank you for
the i thank you for the explanation and
i understand it
completely
but it sounds as though we understand
you've asked for that advice this week
which sounds to be frank like not like
you said
uh the jcvi said we need to make uh take
a look at this question in a wider
context and make some judgments
it looks a bit like what you've decided
is you don't like their non-advice and
you
want some different advice quickly why
is it necessary in that context in that
sense to have a decision out of the
chief medical officers this week which
is what i understand you've asked for
so no i think it's worth just um
reiterating
that uh
the jcvi have said that it is marginally
more beneficial to vaccinate than not to
vaccinate but not enough to make a
national recommendation
uh but they've also been very clear to
say that
their decision is based on things that
they are qualified to look at and they
recognize that there are other factors
that could harm uh the futures of
children and that is why they uh
recommended that medical officers look
at this and then the four ministers um
the secretary of state and the
devolve administration ministers asked
the four chief medical officers to look
at this we're being very careful
and all right right we have some of the
best clinicians in the world and i think
it's
that we can
just very quickly on this uh whatever
you decide
can you assure parents
that
if there is a decision to vaccinate 12
to 15 year olds it will require parental
consent
i can give that assurance absolutely
thank you now is it true as we're
hearing this morning that your boss mr
javid the secretary's state for health
and social care is going to require nhs
staff
to
be vaccinated as a condition of
employment
so you recall uh trevor that
when we consulted on the condition for
deployment of the social care workforce
of course we were looking after the most
vulnerable
people especially those in elderly care
homes who
clearly
covered took its toll on
that consultation came back and we moved
forward on that issue but within that
constellation there was a very clear
feedback that we need to look at the
greater healthcare workforce including
the nhs frontline workforce so i have to
say
and it's worth just putting on the
record one uh they have come forward in
huge numbers to get themselves protected
and vaccinated i think it's over 94
percent of frontline
healthcare workers have come forward
but i think it's only right and
responsible that
we look at the duty of care for health
care workers on the front line and
across the nhs who are looking after
people who when they're entering
hospital are vulnerable to infection and
that
you know we we consult and we will come
back and of course uh publish uh uh that
constitution in due course that
that sounds really like a yes to me that
you are going to make it
a condition of employment unless you
find some reason
some compelling reason not to do so
well i think i think
the right thing to do is to consult and
then
publish that and then return to your
program
and explain uh what uh the consultation
outcome is and then therefore what
decision we make as we did with the
social care workforce
all right well we're going to come to
the social care question now look
winter's coming school's back you've got
some big decisions to make and i'd like
to gallop through uh
two or three of them
when we last spoke i did ask you about
vaccine passports hadn't made up your
mind have you made up your mind about
vaccine passports
so we are looking at um
by the end of september when everyone
has had the opportunity to be fully
uh vaccinated uh for
uh the large venues values that um
could
uh
end up
causing a real spike in infections um
where we need to use
the
certification process and if you look at
what the fa have done they've done so
brilliantly in terms of checking vaccine
status to reopen
football
that is the sort of right
thing to do and we are absolutely um
on track to continue to make sure that
we do that and there's a reason for that
trevor the reason being is that
i as does the prime minister want to
make sure the whole economy remains open
the worst thing we can do
for those uh venues is to have a sort of
open shut open shut um uh strategy
because we see infection rates rise
because of
the close interaction of people that's
how the virus spreads uh if people are
in close
uh spaces in large numbers we see spikes
appearing uh the best thing to do then
is to work with the industry to make
sure that
they can open
safely and sustainably in the long term
and the best way to do that is to check
vaccine status
all right so okay so what i'm hearing
here is two things interestingly
that we will have a certification
process as you describe it what people
refer to as a vaccine passport and that
you
unless something dramatic happens do not
expect another lockdown
well i will do everything in my power
which is why we're working you know
all hours um to make sure we deliver on
the booster program we've had the
interim advice from the jcvi we're
waiting for the cov boost clinical
trials tell us which vaccine is the vast
vaccine to boost the immunity and
increase the durability of the
protection for people
because we want to make sure we continue
to transition
i hope this virus from pandemic to
endemic status so that we can continue
to enjoy all the things that we want to
enjoy we can continue to have our
economy fully opened
and get life back to as normal as we can
make it as quickly as possible nobody
enjoys by the way in this government
certainly not this prime minister having
restrictions on people's freedoms it
goes against dna of this government to
do that but the yes
from the experience of the past 18
months
i want to come to the dna i want to come
to the dna of this government in a
second um one of the things that will
tell us what kind of government you are
is um
the money what are you gonna do about
the money we spent billions 500 billion
by some estimates saving off the
economic cost of independence and the
chancellor it looks as uh though he's
going to have to find the money from
somewhere and there's not that much down
the back of the sofa
let's think about the issue of social
care and benefits um
due to your constituents in stratford
where you are now going to feel
comfortable about cutting universal
credit for 6 million people by 20 pounds
a week
so i think the the one thing that my
constitution stratford realize is that
the
chancellor and this government
has provided a safety net both in terms
of welfare and the increase
in the welfare spend um to protect the
most vulnerable through the coveted uh
crises as well as of course the rest of
the economy 407 billion pounds spent uh
protecting jobs uh at one stage i think
we were up to something like 14 million
plus people on furlough
and of course grants to businesses uh
small business
loans um
the the the uh safety net that i think
this government's provided is one that
people recognize but as people get back
to work as people get back to um
trying to make sure that they they are
able to get lives back
it's only right that we you know try and
make sure that we return the system
where it was where it has been
incredibly generous um all right
safeguarding guys
of course
look
you know that's not going to be
tremendously uh reassuring to many of
the people that we we've been talking to
we were in newcastle uh this week uh
talking to families uh about
uh this situation many on benefits and
so on
uh
one of the store owners who
serves people
customers who are on benefits
said told us that when the prime
minister said that he knew he's only
borrowing red wall votes he should have
grasped that anything
that is borrowed can be taken back are
you ready to pay the political
price on that
and i think an additional point which is
part of the same question
when are we going to see
the social care plan
and are you going to pay for it through
a 1p rise or more on national insurance
so let's try and sort of unpack some of
that
trevor
in terms of
the red wall let's take one example and
that is uh the
uh incredible achievement of ben houch
in the northeast why has he done so well
uh this is a a conservative mayor who
has really delivered um
on the leveling up agenda
in real jobs
and and that was reflected in the result
in
uh his return
but he's not responsible for this you
are what are you are we going to see a
social care plan
will we pay for it through a rise in
national insurance or are we now going
to see another pledge
broken
by uh as in the
uh the uh
triple triple lock on pensions and uh
your
president not to rise raise taxes
so sorry forgive me i was answering the
first half of your question because you
were talking about your uh the red wall
votes that were borrowed and and the
reason uh ben howard was returned was
such a a an overwhelming majority almost
70 percent of the vote is because of
delivery of real reform whether it be t
size airport or the port and the
ambitions around manufacturing therefore
the renewable industry the offshore wind
industry and other parts of the
renewable
and net zero um
huge opportunities that ben houghton has
grasped that is how you deliver uh the
the sort of
those votes coming back
uh the second half
around around social care reform we are
absolutely committed to uh the social
care reform and we will be coming
forward by the end of the year with
those details and when they do uh okay
all right i'll actually come to your
program and discuss them with you
i i will look forward to that minister
thank you very much for your time this
morning but we must move on
well the events in afghanistan over the
past few weeks have variously been
described as a catastrophe a humiliation
and britain's greatest foreign policy
disaster since suez in 1956.
the prime minister and the foreign
secretary have been attacked on all
sides of the house of commons for what
unfolded in kabul and the rest of the
country
but what if anything could have been
done differently i'm now joined by
labour's shadow foreign secretary lisa
nandy
good morning um you've criticized the
government this morning for
what you call complacency complacency
now you you personally abstained on the
deployment
of troops to afghanistan a decade ago
just be let be clear before we get into
the details before this summer
did you think it was right that british
troops should have been in afghanistan
well
i was skeptical about the reasons for
going into afghanistan 20 years ago but
i very much understood like many people
that there was a real and present threat
from al qaeda that had seen more british
citizens that lose their lives than any
other apart from the united states in
the 9 11 attacks and there was an urgent
and pressing priority to make sure that
the capability of al-qaeda was degraded
and that also therefore meant taking on
the taliban government that was in
charge i think what became apparent very
quickly though was that there was a
problem
with what that led to the secondary
objective which became as joe biden has
said in recent weeks about nation
building and trying to build a
democratic inclusive government in
afghanistan alongside the afghan people
proved to be something that was far more
complicated than those who took us into
afghanistan in the first place envisaged
i think there have been a series of
mistakes over the last 20 years by
political parties of all persuasions on
both sides of the atlantic i think at
some stage there has to be a lessons
learned moment but what was avoidable
and what should have been avoidable was
the chaos that we've seen in recent
weeks that's left us reliant on the
taliban for permission to evacuate our
own citizens and the afghans who helped
us and put many british troops in danger
we had 18 months to plan we shouldn't
have ended up here i'll come to that and
i'll come to that in a second but if i
understand what you said clearly i just
want to be sure that i'm interpreting it
properly
you came around to the view that we
should have been there but you thought
what we did or how we executed the
mission
was poor
no actually i think that the work that
the british troops did in afghanistan
working alongside the afghan people is
seriously underrated when i talk to
friends in afghanistan the younger
generation who grew up especially girls
being able to access education millions
of them who would never have had those
opportunities there is a whole
generation of young afghans who have
completely different expectations about
their lives than the generation that
went before because of the work that our
british troops did over two decades not
just in terms of education but landmine
clearance which meant that the economic
opportunities for many afghans were
completely transformed there are there
is a lot to be proud of of the work that
our british troops did over 20 years but
one of the things that many are now
asking is was it all in vain because of
the chaos of the last 18 months and they
are questions that we're going to be
putting to the prime minister in the
house of commons tomorrow and that he
simply has to be able to answer
okay well i mean the question for you is
that do you think then
that the president of the united states
mr biden
should have stuck to his august the 31st
deadline
or do you think that good work of which
you've just spoken should have been
continued irrespective
i think the problem was the hard
deadline whether it was august 31st or a
different date the problem was setting a
hard deadline for withdrawal and that's
a point that my colleague emily
thornbury who was then the shadow
foreign secretary made at the time that
the doha agreement was struck
with president trump was that a phased
withdrawal
would have meant that the afghan troops
the afghan security forces we could have
continued to work with them in order to
support them to continue that battle
against the taliban but instead a hard
deadline signaled to the taliban that
this was simply a waiting game they knew
that they had until the 31st of august
and then all troops so to be clear and
that appears to have had a major impact
on the morale of the afghan forces as
well so we've been very clear
president biden for that decision
to be clear a labor government would
still have british troops in afghanistan
today
no
no we've never we've never argued that
once the united states took a decision
to withdraw from afghanistan we have
accepted
the government position that that it
would have been unsustainable to allow
british troops to continue the foreign
secretary was asked this week at the
foreign affairs select committee where
their efforts made with nato partners to
see if an alternative coalition could
have been put together to allow british
troops and others to remain in
afghanistan and he
gave an answer which is very consistent
with what many of those nato countries
have told me and the labour leader
privately
which is that it would have been
completely unsustainable to do that so
the question became how do you have a
chaotic and orderly withdrawal of troops
and how do you continue to support the
afghan people and protect those gains
that we fought for for 20 years after
we've left that's what the government
ought to have been planning for they had
18 months and they simply didn't do it
okay
all right now talking about supporting
the afghan people we are where we are
should our government be talking to the
taliban
or should it be supporting uh
ahmed masood and the national resistance
army in the panchayat valley can't do
both
i think we have to talk to the taliban
and we've been urging the government for
some time to have a dialogue with the
taliban we have thousands of people
still in afghanistan the afghans who
assisted us but british nationals as
well some of those cases are very very
complex the defense secretary has been
suggesting to mps that they should if
they can they should just try to get to
the border any border and see if they
can get across but without safe passage
many of those people will simply not
reach safety we've got british nationals
in wheelchairs we've got children who've
been separated from their parents we've
got somebody who's on dialysis the truth
is that unless if we want to uphold the
promise and commitment that we made to
our own citizens and to many afghans who
assisted us over recent decades we've
got to have a dialogue with the taliban
we've got to ensure as a priority that
safe passage across the country we've
got to be talking to the taliban as well
about the functioning airport and
whether a country like turkey or qatar
could somehow guarantee the the safe
passage of our citizens out of that
airport this is really pressing and
urgent and there is no choice at this
current stage but to have a dialogue
with the taliban that's different from
diplomatic recognition um which which is
it would be far too premature to to
acknowledge but dialogue is absolutely
essential and the government is right to
have started that belatedly
so this is
uh a clear statement that you would um
engage with taliban of course uh nobody
in the pancho valley is going to like
that very much are they that will be
seen potentially as a betrayal of those
who have stood out against the taliban
that within days
you're talking to people that you have
in recent days actually criticized for
their human rights record
but there's a big difference trevor
between dialogue and diplomatic
recognition this is a regime that came
to power through violence displaced the
democratically elected government that
has been going door-to-door hunting the
uk and people who supported the uk and
the u.s has been rounding up women in
the last 24 hours
and has an appalling human rights record
we've got to be clear-eyed about that
engagement with the taliban and i'm not
for one moment suggesting that we grant
them the legitimacy of diplomatic
recognition as the government of
afghanistan but we have to accept that
because of the chaotic way in which the
government has failed to plan over the
last 18 months we are now in a position
where if we want to evacuate our own
citizens and afghan nationals we've got
to talk to the taliban if we want to
uphold any of the gains of the last 20
years we've got to talk to the taliban
in fact there has been a recognition
even from the outset of the war in
afghanistan that a new government would
mean having some kind of dialogue with
the taliban the united states has been
doing it the united nations has been
doing it and we shouldn't change that
approach now
okay um
if i may ask you uh about some domestic
policies this morning the general
secretary of the trade union congress
has called for
essentially a wealth tax
to pay for
uh nhs recovery
and partic and also for social care is
labor is the labor leadership going to
back that plan
well the first i saw about them was on
the front page of the guardian last
night and i think the broad principle
that francis o'grady is laying out that
those with the broader shoulders should
take some of the burden is absolutely
right fixing the social care crisis is
going to cost a great deal of money and
the prime minister's plan
as we understand it he hasn't shared any
of the details with it but as we
understand it his plan is that he's
going to break his 2019 promise to not
raise national insurance contributions
and load the entirety of the cost of
social care onto the supermarket drivers
supermarket workers the delivery drivers
who are already struggling with high
child care costs high housing costs and
who kept us going through the pandemic i
think that's a really difficult ask of a
group of people who haven't done well
under this conservative government under
the la over the last 11 years and so i
think it's right to say that we need to
think much more creatively about this
and make sure that we don't
load an unsustainable burden onto people
who can't bear it
so so this
so this is labor uh squeezing the rich
until the pips squeak again which in
this context the rich includes people
who live in london and the south east
for example who have quite a lot of
health wealth but it's wrapped up in
houses which are very expensive
this isn't just going to be billionaires
who pay this
this wealth tax is it
i just i don't really accept any of the
premise of that statement i i think that
most people in this country every family
including my own is touched by the
social care crisis it is breaking
families up and down this country and
collectively we've got to find a way to
deal with it if that means that those
who make their money out of
something other than income out of
assets pay a bit more if it means that
people pay a bit more on their income if
it means that we find some kind of
compromise that is sustainable so that
people who can pay a bit more do in
various different ways i think that's
the right approach to take i think we
need to be pragmatic but pensioners on
low incomes who happen to have paid off
their mortgages can't afford can't
generally speaking pay a bit more
well that is the reason why we've got to
learn from the failure to solve this
over the last 20 years because it is
complicated and there will be impacts on
people that um aren't as straightforward
as saying one group of people have to
pay for all of this or another group of
people have to pay for all of this the
dill not report was an attempt to try to
be creative and a bit more flexible
about how we manage this but we've had
this for so long now in 2009 andy
burnham put forward proposals that
collapsed because he couldn't take the
tories with him in 2017 theresa may
sprung proposals on on in her election
manifesto that collapsed because she
couldn't take us or other parties with
her and now boris johnson appears to
have sprung a bunch of proposals on his
own party and can't even take his own
party with him we've got to learn the
lessons we've got to work together to
find a fair sustainable solution to this
that commands
thank you and if the prime minister
wants to talk about that our door is
open
lisa nandy thank you very thank you very
much your time this morning
thank you
well uh we are now moving on to
talk about
what has been called the biggest
overnight cut to social security since
world war ii the 20 pounds a week uplift
to universal credit which was introduced
last year amid the covid 19 pandemic is
due to be scrapped in a month's time but
campaigners experts and even some
conservative mps are calling on the
government to make the top-up permanent
to help low-income families
this week georgia roberts went to
newcastle to speak to families about
what it means for them
when the 20-pound uplift ends this
october is communities like those here
in biker newcastle
that are bracing themselves for the
consequences
ellen is a mum of four who like many
families in the uk began claiming
universal credit after her husband lost
his job because of the crisis
guys
she also suffers from health problems
that can make even getting out of bed
difficult
and working out of the question
now she fears that cuts to her weekly
income will come as a severe blow to her
family and others like her for me to pay
my bills and stuff yes so it's going to
be very hard
it's going to be very hard maybe they
might think that 20 pounds nothing is a
big deal for us it does help us through
along the way honestly
even with that
it can even help paying the kids
swimming or buying a petrol for your car
to
rob around with them going to school and
stuff it might help a lot even sometimes
buying with a
a week a week
mug for the kids bread for the kids it
does help a lot so without 20 pound
taking off i think a lot of family are
going to be struggling
the department for work and pensions
says around 6 million people claim
universal credit in the uk
that's roughly 3 million extra and then
before the pandemic when the 20 pound
goes it's places like the north east
that are set to lose out the most with
the joseph rowntree foundation
estimating around 46
of all working age families with
children in the region will be affected
by the cut
and how many children have they got did
you say four those who provide social
housing in the north east have
experienced first-hand the difference
the uplift has made to tenants
it's been a real lifeline for people
they've really needed to have this extra
20 pounds a week this has given just
that little bit of extra flexibility for
them to think about how they're going to
look after the kids make sure that
people are fed how they're going to deal
with the precarity of the furlough
this is going to have a really serious
impact we know that people were
struggling already before the pandemic
we know from our research that people
were having to make really difficult
decisions about you know whether they
were going to be able to put food on the
table where they're going to be able to
clothe people clothe their children
whether they were going to be able to
heat their houses so i think we're going
to go back to that situation again i
think i would just ask the government to
think again i think they really need to
think about the impact of some of the
changes that they're going to make the
impact it's going to have on everyday
families
and the impact particularly in areas
like the north east
mike medra runs this food bank in baiko
which has a specially designed point
system for people to collect when
shopping for items to lessen the stigma
of asking for much needed help he says
demand has surged during the pandemic
making the uplift even more vital
i don't know how they're going to manage
people people that really really need it
really need it
i just think i think it's a shame
i think it's been a lifeline for a lot
of people and if you're going to do it
the timing has got to be better than
this i think you've got to wait until
everything gets back to normal
because i think if you take it away now
you're you're setting up people to fail
the government's got a difficult job to
do because of you know it's got to start
balancing books
but you're playing with the lives that
are the most vulnerable
and and i don't think
that's worth it
it's areas like this that are key to
the government's plans when they say
they want to level up
leveling up is a really interesting term
because this isn't going to help
this is this is the sort of negative
um action that will damage any
good that's that thing that's as simple
as that
you know
you're playing with people's lives and
and people don't forget
and as boris said you know he's
he's borrowed our votes from the north
yeah and borrowing means you can take
them away as well
food banks both north and south have
told sky news they fear for families in
the coming weeks as a series of covered
lifelines come to an end not only the
20-pound uplift but the furlough scheme
and extended notice for evictions
the real economic skills covered 19 has
left behind for households to grapple
with are about to be revealed
for many families across the uk the
winter ahead is already looking long and
dark
and in response to that report the
government sent us this statement
as announced by the chancellor at the
budget the uplift to universal credit
was always temporary it was designed to
help claimants through the economic
shock and financial disruption of the
toughest stages of the pandemic and it
has done so
universal credit will continue to
provide vital support for those both in
and out of work and it's right that the
government should focus on our plan for
jobs supporting people back into work
and supporting those already employed to
progress and earn
more
well as we've just been hearing there
are huge competing pressures on the
government from those worried about
spiraling public borrowing and those who
are concerned about the impact on public
services and individuals if the
government money taps are turned off too
abruptly and with the chancellor set to
announce his plans shortly in a spending
review at the head of the queue for
special consideration is the nhs of
course facing an uncertain winter after
two years of unprecedented strain to
discuss the pressures bearing down on
the health service i'm now joined by the
new boss of the organization that speaks
for the whole health care system in
england wales and northern ireland
matthew taylor
should nhs employees be required to be
vaccinated as a condition of employment
uh i think that that is not necessary um
the overwhelming majority of nhs staff
are choosing to be vaccinated
and the important thing is to support
people give people the opportunity to be
vaccinated
so
i think we would want to say that there
is no
necessity for uh compulsion
kind of surveillance of people at this
stage because
the
staff themselves are doing the right
thing
so you wouldn't uh be putting any energy
into consulting on that as the
minister told us he was going to do
earlier on
i think if we felt that there was a a
real issue
there then um you know it is something
that needs to be addressed of course
health service workers like anybody else
need to take responsibility for the
decisions they make and the implications
they have for other people but you know
i i think that what we should focus on
is the fact that
overwhelmingly nhs staff
are doing the right thing and indeed you
know working beyond their hours and have
been dealing now for you know 18 months
with
a national crisis and dealing with it uh
heroically so you know i think the
question is not
are there some nhs staff who aren't
vaccinated the question is how do we
support
those nhs staff who have been
doing what we need them to do through
this crisis
let's look at sorry
let's look ahead what's go what's uh on
prospect if the government decides to
uh vaccinate 12 to 15 year olds uh or to
offer booster jab to
older people do you think the system is
resilient enough to cope with that
demand
well we've
seen heroic efforts in terms of
vaccination
and that continues
and there are issues about
supply their issues about capacity and
clearly the government has to make
decisions in terms of who it is that it
prioritizes in relation to this and
these are difficult choices nobody
pretends that they're not
in terms of making a booster um
available to people like myself all the
people who've had two vaccinations and
also to
younger people because of the importance
of ensuring not just trying to minimize
infection rates but also to ensure that
young people are able to carry on in
education
so you know the health service stands
ready as it has done over the last 18
months if given the resources
to lead this national vaccination
program which has so far been a major uh
success but
you know trevor this is part of the the
question of living with uh covid and you
know the first
part of the vaccination program was to
get people vaccinated
um and now we have to think about what
is required in terms of boosters also in
terms of uh flu
vaccination so these are hard choices
it's important that the government is
open about those choices and takes the
best advice that it can in terms of who
it is we should be prioritizing
you published a report this week which
to be honest described a system which is
pretty much
on the edge you uh your report said that
covert 19 had had a seismic impact
unlike anything
the nhs has faced in its history and it
to describe the last two months as
winter in summer
do you believe that you've got the beds
and the people the trained staff to get
us through to next spring
yeah it's tough and you're absolutely
right trevor that that the leaders or
members of our organization tell us that
it feels and we're just coming out of
summer that when it feels like a
midwinter crisis all parts of the nhs
not just hospitals the ambulance service
gps community mental health services we
are running on hot
and you can't do that forever and so
that's one reason why it's incredibly
important to get some clarity from the
government about the funding for the
rest of this year that we sustain uh
that funding and that we have the
funding that we need on the assumption
that the pressures of covid are going to
continue and that's what it looks like
is going to happen so the two big
challenges for the health service are
funding the ongoing costs of covid and
that's the patients in hospital over
7000 in hospital right now ppe
um the pressure on mental uh health
services long covid which is a major
issue and then secondly the backlog we
have
as we know well over five million people
on waiting lists the secretary of state
himself has said that he thinks that
that fear could rise uh a great deal
more and we need to fund that care as
well
now yes there are major issues about
workforce there are issues about uh the
kind of capacity that we have but
it is important to say that if you give
the health service the resources that it
needs it does the job
and even in these last few months while
we're still coping with kobit we have
seen substantial progress in relation to
those people who've been waiting the
longest time
and we've seen progress also in other
critical areas like making sure that we
are checking people for the danger of a
cancer diagnosis so
despite these pressures where the nhs
has the resources it makes a difference
but we need that resourcing to to
continue
firstly for the rest of this year and
then for the years ahead
matthew taylor thank you very much
indeed
thank you
prime ministers like policemen seem to
be getting younger which means that when
they step away from office they don't
necessarily leave the stage and for the
most part their pronouncements born of
experience carry weight
which is why an angry blast this morning
from gordon brown aimed at the west's
leaders will be read and noted in
washington london brussels and berlin
the former pm and chancellor has
attacked western leaders for sitting on
their hands while africa's vaccination
rates are among the glowest across the
globe
in a striking phrase he says if the
world were a single country it would be
a failed state he joins us now from
scotland
good morning mr brown
you've written what i think can only be
described as a furious article this
morning accusing rich western nations
are sitting on their hands while africa
is ravaged by covid what's
made you so cross
look seventy percent of the west has
been vaccinated
only two percent
in africa and actually in all the other
low-income countries of the world
so 98 are unprotected it's bad for them
it's bad for us because the disease will
come back to haunt us from africa and
hurt even the fully vaccinated here with
new variants but what i'm showing this
morning
is that there are hundreds of millions
of unused vaccines
that are either stored or are on order
for delivery to europe and america
including the united kingdom
300 million by the end of this month 500
million by the end of october a billion
by the end of december
these vaccines could save thousands of
lives in africa and you've talked about
very important issues this morning and
they are important but no issue we're
talking about could save more lives than
a policy decision by the richest
countries that these surplus unused
stockpiled stocks could actually go to
the poorest countries who desperately
need them to protect even the nurses and
their health workers who remain
unvaccinated against this disease
with the best will in the world though
the realist might say
we can't actually be sure and it's not
their fault but we can't actually be
sure that the african nations can
distribute
those millions of vaccines it's
difficult and they don't have the
networks they don't have the
capabilities that is is the problem just
one of will
or is it one of capability
well that's not what the africans tell
me i've talked to many african leaders
in the last few days and they're
desperate to get the vaccines and they
can't get hold of them and in fact for a
few weeks
europe has been raiding africa for
vaccines and taking them from from a
production facility in south africa to
europe so we are doing the worst
possible thing when it comes to making
the world safer against corvette if we
leave these people unprotected if it
spreads uninhibited it will come back to
us
but it's absolutely clear to me that we
not only have the stocks in the west
that would enable us to vaccinate the
over 12s
to do the boosters
but also to be able to send these stocks
that are on order or in warehouses
across to the countries that need the
most it's really a failure of
international coordination
the vaccines are increasingly there one
and a half billion produced every month
two billion by january
record supplies are going to be
available but the distribution is all
wrong and we are hoarding and
stockpiling when we should actually be
delivering them to the people who need
them knowing that if we need more
vaccines we have another about that we
need to deal with we can get vaccines
very quickly
you were at the center of the last time
we had
the this kind of need for a concerted
global push on something specific and
i'm now referring to the financial
crisis back in 2008. um if you were
still in office what would you be saying
to your g7 colleagues i mean what what
physically do they have to do
they've got to call a summit an
emergency summit in the next two weeks
they've got to deal with this urgent
problem that if left unaddressed
thousands of people are at risk of dying
when i dealt with the g20 in 2009 i
realized one thing you can't rely on the
imf and the world bank and the un good
as they are you cannot rely on them only
the leaders can make these decisions
only the leaders who control the
allocation of vaccines in their own
countries can decide to transfer them to
other countries or to transfer the
options for them so it's really up to
joe biden boris johnson
angela merkel and mr macron and france
these are the leaders that can by
getting together make a decision
everybody can contribute the money can
be made available
it's a question of getting the vaccines
into the right arms in the right place
as quickly as possible and we are
talking about tens of thousands of lives
that are at risk now if we do nothing
about this
from your experience um
mrs brown
there is something really profoundly
puzzling and disturbing about this i
mean we have a vast international
machinery the un the who the imf
plus the g7 g7 summit and something as
simple as moving vaccines from
europe to let's say south africa or west
africa
should have been sorted out by now isn't
this an indictment if you like of the
international multilateral system about
which you know nobody everybody
never stops boasting uh about how
important and useful this corporation is
yet multilateral cooperation is not
working here they had a chance in june
at the g7 to allocate
the
11 billion vaccines that were needed to
make sure we had a plan to get them to
those where the urgency was greatest
but they failed to do this in june now
they've got another chance they can meet
on the margins of the united nations and
get it done and this is really a test of
multilateral cooperation if you can't
distribute the vaccines equitably when
the vaccines are available what else
will we fail to do if we can't do this
and so i believe that in the next two
weeks a decision will have to be made
i'm pressing for this meeting to take
place and so are others you'll find
african leaders will be demanding it too
faith and church leaders know that this
vaccine divide between vaccine rich and
vaccine poor is really a terrible stain
it's a moral failure on the part of the
whole of the world and of course it's in
everybody's interest that people are
vaccinated in every continent because
clearly nobody is safe until everybody
is safe
this is a second example of something
that
i think has a much deeper meaning
and i'm first example being the exit
from afghanistan that the era of liberal
interventionism
uh by the west led by america
is over isn't it it feels like actually
there isn't a leader anymore and that
all of the things that brought
relief to kosovo sierra leone and so on
no longer obtain is that where we are in
the world right now
well i think what president biden done
is said america no longer wants to be
the world's policeman
but look the america and the richer
nations have got to be the world's
problem solver
you may not want to intervene militarily
but if you've got the vaccines or if
you've got the wealth and you know
there's an urgency to solve problems of
poverty or problems of ill health or
problems of illiteracy then you've got
to do something about it and i think
what we're really talking about is how
we can intervene in a way that is
purposeful in a way that gets results in
a way that is not counterproductive and
one signal of that would be of course
taking action on vaccines and i hope
that can happen very soon so so yes if
the world of the world as i said was one
country it would be declared or
designated a failed state but there is
scope to do something about it in this
instance it requires about four people
to get round the table and to make a
decision and once they make that
decision we can save thousands of lives
so i i it's a test of international
cooperation is there the will to do
things or are we to retreat into vaccine
nationalism and eventually still to
america first britain first china first
india first and so on that is not the
way that the world is going to solve
problems of climate change solve
problems of financial instability solve
problems obviously of pandemics
it's i mean
something has shifted though hasn't it
um
if i can put it
in perhaps not too trivial away if an
alien
uh were to land on the planet uh
now uh in previous days you would have
said and the aliens said take me to your
leader in previous days we would have
given him the address
or her the address of the white house
wouldn't we um
that's not going to happen today these
things don't happen
just by themselves they have to be led
and i suppose what i'm really asking
from your experience and your background
where is that leadership going to come
from
you know that's the question that ronald
reagan asked mikhail gorbachev if an
asteroid arrived on the planet would you
help us and gorbachev said yes and
reagan said me too
and it's cooperation that matters so
perhaps it's not one leader it's the
recognition that we are a multi-lateral
world
america used to act multilaterally in a
unipolar age it seems to act
unilaterally in a multi-polar age at
least under president trump what we've
got to realize is that these problems
can be solved only by cooperation in a
multi-poorer world you've got to get
people around the table we did that in
2009 to solve or to try to solve the
financial crisis we've got a vaccine
crisis we've got a health crisis we are
going to see in the next few weeks that
we've got a climate change crisis now no
one country can solve that they've got
to find a way of working together and i
hope that for the sake of the planet we
can find a way of getting the different
leaders of different countries who are
practicing perhaps nationalistic
policies at the moment they've got to
find a way of showing that cooperation
is the only way forward
okay i know that uh you're not uh
directly involved in domestic politics
anymore but um i'd look a bit silly if i
didn't ask you about the uh current
financial and economic uh situation
facing this country um
somebody's gonna have to pay for the
trillions that we've committed to
dealing with the pandemic and we've got
the social care uh thing coming down the
track and it's been there since you were
a chancellor um
two questions really
well first question where would you be
looking for the money would you support
a rise in the national insurance tax and
would you support the tucs proposal for
a wealth tax
well we did the national insurance rise
in 2002-3 and that paid for the health
service to expand massively i think 100
000 more nurses
and 30 000 more doctors i always said
you'd have to come back to this 10 years
on because we've got rising population
pressures rising elderly technology is
costing more and of course the pandemic
so you've got to look at how you can
finance this first out of growth we need
to get back to growth the only way of
reducing debt and deficits is through
growth and secondly looking at the fair
allocation of resources the problem i
see at the moment
is we've got a government divided
between the small state conservatives
who want to cut taxes and cut spending
and the one nation conservatives who
understand they've got to do something
about it and i suspect that that
division goes right from top to bottom
of the conservative party between north
and south between rural and urban areas
between suburbs
and the shires and they've got to sort
out these divisions within the party to
come to a solution because the health
service has got to be funded
and we've got to get out of this
pandemic by making sure that children
for example are not in poverty and
that's why the cut in universal credit
in a few weeks time is completely
unacceptable it puts six million
families further into poverty so the
government's got to resolve this
conflict which didn't exist uh 20 years
ago within our government that clearly
exists in this government between small
state conservatives and one nation
conservatives and i fear that that
rents asunder the whole conservative
party
but what if trump if it were up to you
now would you support a rise in national
insurance you've done it before would
you say right
see this is a bit different you've got
social care now
and you've got to fight provide a
long-term solution to social care
so you're looking at a social solution
not just for a year or two but for five
10 15 20 years
and therefore national insurance must be
one of the
issues for consideration but you've got
to be thinking how can we pay for this
over the long term
because this elderly
issue for providing social care is
something that is going to grow it's
going to become more intensified over
the next few years and therefore the
measures that you take have got to be
looked at very carefully and they've got
to be based on what you can afford and
what you're prepared to do and ask
people to do over the long term so i've
been looking at a number of options
gordon brown thank you very much indeed
for your time this morning
thank you thank you
well prime minister and foreign
secretary will be no doubt be grappling
with some of those big questions about
britain's role in the world over the
coming months but for the moment they
still face intense scrutiny about how
they handled the withdrawal from
afghanistan and how they will handle the
coming humanitarian and security
challenges
tom tugginhat conservative mp and chair
of the foreign affairs committee
joins me now um
tom tuggenheim just very uh quickly from
the foreign affairs point of view do you
understand uh gordon brown's anger on
the vaccination question and do you
agree with him that this is a
responsibility that should be in the
lapse of g7 leaders
of course i understand it and most
importantly i think it's fundamentally
in britain's interest to uh make sure
vaccinations are rolled out as quickly
as possible around the world for the
very simple reason that we know about
all these variants coming up around the
corner you know we've had a
kent variant in indian variant and no
doubt there'll be many other variants uh
uh you know on their way and the faster
we vaccinate the fewer develop variants
and the less likely there is of
subsequent uh cross infection in the uk
so this is simply self-interest and i
that's why i think we should do it
uh more important to get vaccines out to
uh developing countries than to
vaccinate children
well i don't know that's i'm afraid i'm
going to have to ask scientists on that
one um and it's not my area of expertise
so i'm i'm talking to people about it at
the moment actually funnily enough
all right well let's turn to afghanistan
um
you were plainly really deeply affected
by
what happened
and the fact that
many of the people that you worked with
in your four years i think in
afghanistan
uh were left behind
how many people do you think remain
uh who need to get out the vaccines
minister talked about low hundreds
well i don't know again um but i've
certainly had contact with um the best
part of uh best part of a hundred and i
don't suppose for a moment that i'm in
i've had contact with the majority so um
you know it's very hard to say and and
for everyone i've been in contact with
there's a family attached so low
hundreds strikes me as a an optimistic
uh optimistically low number
can you say anything about the effort in
which you've been involved you'd i i
read that you said you basically hadn't
slept for weeks because of this but
you've been involved in efforts to
bring people out
well there's a collection of us who've
been uh working in different ways to try
and get uh folk out and we've had uh in
earlier days we had more success we've
had mixed success recently but i mean
it's it it's really a series of uh
people us british connecting individuals
we know to
uh safe houses we know and and and
moving people around um
it's extremely uh fraught and it's
getting harder as the taliban and
various different groups that are
affiliated with it um get better get
more in place get more structured so you
know we're seeing for example that the
biometric information that's been left
behind is increasingly being used at
checkpoints and that has seen certainly
at least
one individual we know um captured and
sadly disappeared and i'm told uh by
others of uh several others
there's a fundamental question about the
way that our government has to behave
and that is what does it think about the
taliban do you
believe the taliban when they say this
is a new model they're going to be
different this time for example on the
equality of women and uh
and even if
they are
different in kabul and kandahar can they
enforce that change across the country
well trevor this is the fundamental
question who is the taliban i mean i
know who mula barada is and i know that
he negotiated in doha and spent two
years giving the us the run around
conceding nothing and accepting
everything
i know who mularoma's son
yakub is and i know that he has very
limited support in the quest for sure
but is used as a figurehead i also know
who sirajadin haqqani is who
allied with al-qaeda for many years
introduced suicide bombing to
afghanistan and now controls kabul and i
know who many of the drugs dealers and
informal networks in the south are after
all those of the people we faced in
helmand for so many years
but the idea that this is a single unit
and that by negotiating uh with one
group in doha you achieve result in
kabul i'm afraid is not really true i
mean this is this is a very very divided
clan based uh mob based uh organization
think of it more like the mafia than a
government
and you'll have a better idea as to how
it works
is there therefore any point in talking
to the taliban what would you recommend
should we be talking to the taliban and
if so which bit of it you you've
identified at least three streams and
we know that there are many more as well
as the local warlords
well the uk has always had a policy of
uh
you know reaching out in different ways
to different groups i have to say i
think formal talks with the taliban are
somewhat bizarre idea given that it
doesn't have a formal structure you know
the fact that it still hasn't formed a
government what is it now uh two three
weeks after it uh it took kabul is
partly an indicator of the divisions
within the organization you know it is
it is fighting within itself as to what
it does so the idea that um these talks
are meaningful in a traditional sense uh
i'm afraid they're not and the idea that
the taliban has changed again i mean you
know this is it's got a much slicker pr
outfit i don't know who it's hired but
it's got it's got a similar group to the
people who are doing isis pr in in
northern syria
but the reality that it's changed the
way it treats women or or murders uh
minorities like the hazard minority it's
complete rubbish no that's still as
brutal and vicious as they were
one one very quick question if i may ask
you you interrogated the foreign
secretary this week and i think i'd
rather embarrass him by quoting from a
document
that he evidently didn't recognize as
his own department's work
did you come away from that encounter
thinking that this was the best foreign
secretary that the government could
actually find in its ranks
look i came away from that thinking that
there are a lot of questions that the
government needs to sort out and the
most important one today is one that's
been summarized by general the lord
richards in a piece an article on
conservative home website which talks
about having a unity of process the one
thing that really concerned me about
that hearing actually there's a lot of
backward looking stuff in that hearing
for very obvious reasons because we need
to understand what went wrong the one
thing that concerned me going forward
was the fact that we do not have a
single person a single minister a single
official responsible for helping people
who we owe duty of care to in
afghanistan and getting them out and i'm
delighted that vicky atkinson is doing
that in the uk that's fantastic but we
need somebody doing the same thing in
afghanistan honestly i'm trying to press
you on this tom but um you don't think
he's up to it do you
well look trevor my job as the chair of
the foreign invest committee is to
challenge whoever sits in that in that
seat so you're always gonna see me being
somewhat more uh aggressive towards a
foreign secretary than towards any other
minister that's literally the job i've
been asked to do by parliament so
you know i'm not going to get into this
conversation for the simple reason that
my job is to challenge rather like your
job is to challenge if somebody asked
you whether or not a minister was up to
it or not up to it you'd avoid the
question because your job is to
challenge whoever the minister is and so
you know that's what i've got to do
tom toucan i think we understand each
other completely thank you very much
indeed for your time this morning
thanks trevor
that's it from us this week stay with us
now for the take for analysis of today's
show with sky's deputy political editor
sam coats
[Music]